uh okay so uh
so i'll talk about something that uh
i've been thinking a lot about which is
uh graph uniformization
so the idea is you take a big graph and
then uh
maybe it looks some way and then you try
to
uniformize it so it looks nicer so and
the reason i say uniformization is
because i really i mean
i intended to harken back to like
conformal uniformization the riemann
mapping theorem obviously you have to
mention people from the 1800s so
i did like riemann's thesis in 1850
where he
proved the riemann mapping theorem um
and so i can i can uh you know there are
a number of different ways to you can
you can state such a problem and
actually have many applications to
things like
unique games conjecture something called
the thin trees conjecture and so on
uh so okay so the classical part is that
i want to relate to
sort of uniformization reminding
geometry the neo part is that i want to
do it for graphs
and then of course the subtitle of the
conference is uh
additive combinatorics so at the end the
punch line will involve some already
and at least four applications of koshi
shorts which is the way
we are measuring things i guess this
week i heard people in the hallway you
know i use koshi shorts six times
okay uh good so the
okay so for this purpose i'll i'll give
a okay but all of these uh
notions of uniformization that i care
about they have something in common so
let me talk about one problem targeting
back to one of the first uses of
uniformization in romanian geometry
and then uh you will like the framework
will be sort of more general at the end
i'll give some open questions
related to rather disparate set of
things
uh okay so the the problem i want to
talk about is uh
eigenvalues of the of graphs
so of course there is a field of
spectral graph theory which tries to
relate the eigenvalues the spectrum the
eigenvectors of a graph to geometric and
combinatorial properties
that the graph has so let me just
give you some okay so here's a graph now
we'll think about this operator on the
graph which is the laplacian
so uh it maps functions on the vertices
to other functions on the vertices
and here's the normalization i'll use
the laplacian
of a graph it maps f to the function
which takes x to
you look at all the neighbors of x and
you take f of x minus f of y
so you might not like this normalization
i don't like this normalization but it
will be the simplest
this is called the combinatorial
uh okay so this is the operator and i
guess the one other thing we should know
about this is uh
the quadratic form associated to it so
the quadratic form
as most people are familiar measures
the uh the energy of f
over edges of the graph so i have a
function on the vertices
the if i take the inner product of f
with the laplacian i get some
uh some kind of potential energy of f
over the edges of the graph
okay and uh and then i want to talk
about so now this thing is a
positive semi-definite
has a spectrum say
like this uh and uh okay i want to say
something about how the
eigenvalues of the graph the eigenvalues
relate to the
geometric and combinatorial structure of
the graph there are many problems you
can say in this way
uh let me go back to something
very simple so
in romanian geometry if you go back to
1970 it was proved okay so
where's the first place that you can
talk about sort of non-trivial things
going on with eigenvalues you can look
at eigenvalues of
surfaces okay so these are very simple
objects and it was proved by harrison 70
that
so i should say by the way that if
you're coming from geometry
sort of uh usually lambda one is eq so i
will you know
lambda2 is the first non-true eigenvalue
in romanian geometry lambda one is the
first match of the eigenvalue
but uh so what herz proved is that uh
if you have uh so suppose m is some
romanian metric
on the two sphere so you just take some
metric on the two sphere uh then the
actually the the smallest non-trivial
eigenvalue is uh
is extremely for the flat to sphere
itself okay so uh you have to normalize
by the volume
okay but this is what hersh proved in uh
it's non-trivial uh it's the first
non-trivial one
the first one is zero the first this is
the event
for many folds yeah even for well even
for men i didn't define what is the
laplacian but if you take the laplace
beltrami operator on a manifold then
uh yeah you will see that the constant
functions are annihilated by it so
uh but they just so it makes maybe it
makes more sense to start the numbering
earlier but this can be
it's a matter of aesthetics okay so this
was proved in uh in 1970
and then um let me say this will be
slightly out of order
so this is for ramani and mattress on
the two sphere so you can ask about
what happens for say the graph
theoretical version which would be to
look at the
second eigenvalue of a planar graph and
the spearman and tang prove that
okay so for g planar that
you have something like
this where for for g
planar and again n is number of vertices
and d max is the maximum degree of the
graph
okay they didn't actually know about
hershey's bound their proofs are very
similar
i'll say something in a second about the
proof so can you just
repeat this for what for any money for
any romanian metric on the tooth here no
no
yeah so you you can you can you know
every such thing you can basically take
you know you take a just a
uh a non-negative function on a
two-sphere it will give you some
hills and valleys and it gives you every
money and metric and you can
look at the eigenvalues uh okay
and then in the 80s after this work of
uh
first uh stl asked
what what happens for the rest of the
spectrum so is the is the flat sphere
uh extremal for the rest of the spectrum
so he asked
the question is it the case that you can
get some bound like this
okay flat sphere you mean the normal
flux yeah sorry okay yeah
okay so yes uh constant curvature
so maybe flat is
uh okay uniform good form
uh okay and then this was resolved uh
this was resolved by
corvar in 93. so the answer is yes
and then let me mention the question
i'll talk about today which was uh
also in newspapers pioneer tang they
asked uh
they answered the same thing is true for
graphs so so
uh so this is kind of the simplest
setting in which you might want to do
some kind of uniformization and you'll
see
what it means in a second uh do you have
a similar kind of bound so
uh well we can let's just assume the
degree is constant but here's the
conjecture that's the question and let
me say that uh
that uh well for all i know and for all
well no one ever
claimed to me otherwise that this uh
the graph case seems stronger than the
manifold case so you can prove it for
the graph case there is
a fairly easy reduction in cruiser for
the manifold case this
this direction uh i don't know of any
such proof
so it seems it seems genuinely harder to
prove it for graphs than four
surfaces but it would be great if
somebody came up with yeah
resorted in 2009 but what's that i
thought that time resorted in 2009 but
fortunately i'm also a co-author on the
paper so
so uh yeah so with with uh calendar
price and tang
uh in 2009 uh
we proved that the answer is is yes okay
thank you
okay uh and uh yeah
okay so the and the and the okay so now
let's say something about the proof and
in the process you'll see what i mean by
uniformizing a graph and
uh and then we'll see where uh
sort of the combinatorial argument comes
in okay so uh
let's see all right it's good um
okay so the first thing we have to
understand is how can we how can we and
by the way feel free to
you know ask questions at any time uh
i have some fear that i could run out of
time and it's your fault that's better
than if it's my fault
so so is this is this good job thank you
is this picture a smiling person with
four eyes
you should ask your therapist what it
means when you see a smile everywhere
this is uh
but uh you is very happy even when you
should be upset he's always always happy
okay uh
now i'm off at last forgot what i was
doing okay
yeah so okay so how can you okay so how
can you hope to prove such a thing
well first you can write down what is
the case eigenvalue so you can write
down the variational
characterization so let's see you want
to minimize
over all subspaces
of functions of dimension k and then
look at the maximum over non-zero
functions in the subspace
okay something like this here's the k
the variational definition of
the characterization of the case
eigenvalue okay so now first of all if
you want to balance it like this it's
very hard because
there is this linear algebraic condition
that says you have to find the entire
subspace of functions
and then you have to you have to bound
this called the rayleigh quotient
for every single one and uh i mean the
linear algebraic structure
is is separate from the structure of the
you know
the laplacian right i mean it's this
this subspace is sort of unrelated to
the geometry of laplacian so this is
sometimes a difficult thing to do uh so
there is something nicer you can try to
bound
uh which is to replace this
orthogonality constraint that you have a
k dimensional subspace by some
combinatorial uh
property so here is uh something else
you might like to bound
instead of looking for a k dimensional
subspace i'll just look for k functions
and i want the force of k functions to
be orthogonal
so if you're thinking combinatorially
the easiest way to do that is just
to have them all have disjoint supports
so
okay so on any particular vertex of the
graph that most one function is non-zero
okay uh okay so then we just now we just
have k functions
so i'm replacing orthogonality right the
whatever base is a function of the space
by
a much stronger property that the
function that is generally supported um
and then
okay and then my then maybe my goal is
now just to bound
k rayleigh equations okay and the reason
this is nicer is because in order to
bound this i mean
now i can think geometrically right i
have a i have some space
and i'm trying to construct functions of
this joint support so i can i can
construct the function here and then i
can say okay i'm not allowed to use this
part of the space anymore
you can do this and okay so it smell
you know this is a something that seems
easier to reason about
um okay so on the one hand it's very
easy to see that uh
but if you can if you can if you can
bound this number then you can bound
these numbers okay
you just take this the corresponding
subspace would be the span of these k
functions
and you get a factor of two just because
edges have two endpoints
uh you have to write it down but it's
it's very simple
and you might worry that you're uh you
might worry that you've
sort of made the problem much harder for
yourself but actually there's a
result we proved uh
with cheyenne uh
and luca
last year that says uh actually
uh this sort of combinatorial eigenvalue
is never too much worse
than the corresponding algebraic i can
tell you so
something like uh okay something like
this
so like there's no quantifiers here but
this doesn't have anything to do with
so sorry this this this slide of the
board has nothing to do with uh
planar graphs this is for any graph so
you take any graph
in fact you can take any sort of markov
operator it's very general
uh if you if instead of looking over
the k dimensional subspace of functions
you look over just these jointly
supported functions
the corresponding eigenvalue does not
lose too much okay so
uh we won't need this but it just sort
of gives someone faith that
you're not bounding something crazy and
in fact in the paper we prove that if
the graph is
is nice if the graph is planar then
like you know so in the planar case
actually you can just get some
really some absolute constant okay so
okay so the bounding this is sort of uh
uh
is without loss okay so this is what
we're going to try to do now to bound uh
to find k functions to put it on the
graph each of which has a small rayleigh
quotient
if you think about what it means we're
trying to find k functions
each of which is which are digitally
supported and each of which is pretty
smooth
we're trying to keep the functions from
being too crazy okay
let's go any questions about this
so now what i want to say is that uh the
difficult part of this goal
is the paper that does this for
for metrics on the sphere also
constructs this jointly supported
functions the paper also constructed
generally supported functions
uh it's a bit uh if you want to know i
can tell you afterwards
how it works and why it doesn't hold for
the and why it doesn't seem to work for
graphs
but it's basically because the paper
uses the uniformization theorem which is
just weaker in the case of graphs
and there's not enough uh it uses it in
a very strong way
it's it's it's uh it doesn't seem like
enough uh
to have just the graph version okay so
let me okay so now
i want to construct k this generally
supported functions now you have to take
this leap of faith
uh the difficult part of doing that is
that
when the graph when a graph is given to
me it looks something like this
uh i mean i you know it doesn't have a
very nice you know
if i just look at a graph it just you
know we sort of like the the base
geometry where each edge has length one
that i don't see that's necessarily the
some nice structure there can be
looking crazy so really the hard part
about constructing these functions is
spreading the graph out
so that there's enough space to
construct them okay so this is uh
okay so uh
okay so i want to put some nice metric
on the graph and
once i have a nice metric it will be
fairly easy to construct these functions
so what does that what does the metric
mean okay so uh you can think of edge
weighted metrics or vertex weighted
metrics for this
purpose i'll use vertex weights
okay so i have a i have a weight
function on the vertices and then
associated this wave function i can just
look at the lengths of shortest paths in
the graph so the
this distance will be the uh
so the distance between x and y will be
the the w
length of the shortest
x-y path in g
okay so this is how i'll think about
deforming the graph i can put weights on
the vertices and it makes certain things
farther apart and certain things closer
together
and then if you want to solve this
problem let me tell you uh
okay what you need is a is a is a
way of putting weights on the graph that
spreads the mass out
a fair bit so uh so here's something
which suffices
um to have a weight that satisfies
on the one hand that the say the average
uh weight squared of vertex is at most
one
and okay so this is one thing we have
some balance on the
total weight we can put on the on the
graph and
i want to have some kind of constraints
you know it's not good for me if the
graph is sort of crumbles up so i want
to have some kind of constraints that
say that the grid that no small
that no sufficiently large piece of the
graph can be trivial
okay so the non-triviality constraint
will be
okay julia warned you that it was
running out
uh yeah the non-triviality constraint
will be okay something like this
and uh for the case of
for the case of trying to bound the case
eigenvalue this is the kind of weight
that one would need to find
okay so uh and if you really want to do
this
uh
again this is everything here is general
except for the value of delta
which will depend on the graph but uh if
you want to spread the space out here's
what i mean
you assign weights to the vertices like
you can think about as a romanian metric
on the graph such that the total
volume is bounded uh and then you would
like that every large enough subset
so in fact here that we can put doesn't
really uh size bigger than n over k
uh doesn't collapse in this metric yeah
at the distance you actually include the
weights at the endpoints
uh yeah but i mean yes you include the
weight to the endpoints
if you really you could do but there are
a few things you could do but they're
all the same up to a constant factor so
it doesn't really
matter okay so the point is that if you
want to construct these functions
uh it suffices to find some way of
spreading out the graph
and to do that uh it suffices to find
the weight satisfying these kind of
properties this is you can think about
this as
a some kind of romanian metric on the
graph where
the sets of measure one over k don't
collapse
they're all big okay so i claim that it
suffices to
find such a thing all right
and now we okay and and i've set this up
in a nice way that's uh
uh sort of i skipped a few steps in in
what you might do at home if you were
doing it by hand so that actually the
space of all such things is a complex
set
so uh if you think about these phrases
as a convex program
where the the variables are the w of v's
then this this is
this is a set of this is a set of linear
constraints and this is a
i mean this is a sphere so this is a
convex set so this is this is a convex
set so in particular
to find such a way i can apply duality
this is sort of this is why i set things
up like this
the natural thing you might do uh at
home is to have a some kind of square
here
but then this makes it no longer a
convex set because it's the
becomes the complement of a of a sphere
okay
so there is a koshi schwartz hidden
somewhere there
okay that doesn't count as one of the
koshi shorts by the way
okay so now you want to construct uh
such a metric i guess i should say that
uh
if you only care about the case k equals
two so which will explain how
how both of these things work if you
only care about the case k equals two
then there is a nice way to do it okay
so look at k equals two
uh and now you have a planar graph so
there is a
the kobe uh
uh sort of a circle packing
representation of a planer graph which
says
that every every planer sorry this is a
smile with four eyes
let's uh that every planar graph can be
drawn
uh as the tangency graph of a bunch of
disks on the unit sphere
okay all right so this is how a tendency
graph works
uh right and so on
so if you if you okay so now continue
drawing the graph
uh i stopped for sake of the sake of
time if you set the weight of a vertex
equal to the radius
of the corresponding disk
right v okay
then well then you have a bound on the
total volume right w
v squared is the most i mean it's the
most this is the say the unit sphere in
r3 so this is at most sum constant
um uh and then if you want to get this
uh this condition just for sizes of set
to size at least half
it will not you cannot just take any old
circle packing and get it
but uh if you apply an appropriate
merbus transformation then this
condition will be true
for k equals two okay that's a
non-trivial fact it requires a
topological argument
that actually hershey and spina ting
came up with independently
uh but there exists there's a rich
enough family of
circle-preserving maps that you can take
one of them which sort of
sorry which covers the such that when
you apply it the
the sort of the graph is spread out
enough on the sphere has to satisfy this
constraint for k equals two
okay so so this is a good this is a good
uniformization of the graph for for
small k no one knew how to do it for k
equals three not in the romanian setting
not in the graph setting
okay so yes i'm not
sure how you get the distance from the
waves
it's just the shortest path distance
uh the sum of the weights of the
vertices occurring in the past oh what
did you
sorry what was the other interpretation
uh
that the length of an edge was the
difference the absolute value of the
difference of the weights i see
and then the part was the sum of those
okay so this is my mistake i thought uh
but now we're on the same page so the
the length of the path is the the given
a path the length of the path is the sum
of the weights of the vertices occurring
the path
the shortest path is you take the
infimum overall such pass
you have a question guy okay
uh why do you want this constraint to be
quadratic instead of linear well if you
look at the
i mean what you should ask is why the
second contrary is linear instead of
quadratic no no
if you look here you have the ratio of
two quadratic terms so it makes sense
you want something quadratic
uh here i've used you know here it was
safe to use kosher shorts here it wasn't
uh
what's specific to k equal to 2 why does
it work for higher k
um
basically you can rewrite this
constraint so that it's just a single
constraint for k equals two it does you
know it looks like it could be
n choose n over two constraints but for
k equals two you can write this as a
single constraint
and then you have a single you know we
have essentially
uh let's see you have essentially a one
parameter family of merbias
transformations and it's enough to get
this single constraint correct
but the second you have more than a
single constraint there's not a rich
enough family of
circle-preserving transformations to get
this right
okay so the the last step uh is now
to understand this extreme these
extremal metrics
uh by a connection to um
to flows in the graph okay so
it doesn't mean like richie flow or
any kind of geometric flow although okay
it's a good question whether the two
flows have anything in common
uh uh okay so what is a flow so let's
let p be the set of all the
say simple paths in our graph and then a
flow is just
a function that maps paths to
non-negative numbers
and i want to associate two values to
this flow one is the something like
f of uv which will be the
the total flow between
u and v right so have u have v
there are many paths with n's point u
and v and
if i sum f along all these paths i get
some number
that's the flow between u and v yeah and
the other thing i want is sum is uh
this notion which is the amount of flow
going through the vertex u
so this is the so basically given any
any non-negative function on paths i can
define these two quantities associated
with them
this is the amount of flow
uh this has to have
you're going to minimize something
eventually so it will not make sense to
take non-simple paths but let's say
simple paths
uh okay so these are flows these turn
out to be the dual objects to metrics
just because when you write down the
constraints of the triangle inequality
uh well the flows are the dual variables
corresponding to the constraint one
current chain for every path
uh and then what kind of uh sort of if
you want to find the
the best metric here okay so for
instance you want to maximize this value
delta
uh what does it correspond to in the
flow setting well it corresponds to
a problem that looks the following you
want to look over
all flows you want to minimize
sort of the the l2 norms of the
congestion at the vertices okay so
you look at every vertex how much flow
is going through it you want to minimize
the square
subject to some constraints okay so i'm
just
do some constraints so let me tell you
uh first what the constraints are for k
equals two
once you rewrite the program okay so
this is only
okay so for k equals two it's advised to
have the following constraints just that
the
uh
the flow will send uh one unit between
every pair of vertices
okay so like i have this flow which is
ending one year between every pair of
vertices
and now my goal is to uh if you think
about it for duality
in order to show that it's not so clear
because i didn't write the but in order
to show that you can get such a large
value of delta in other words in order
to show that you can spread out the
the graph using this uh construction
it's
uh one needs to show that for for every
flow satisfying these constraints
the total uh sort of
congestion incurred is large that's
what's required here okay and the larger
you can
and in fact if you look at optimality
the the extremal metric you should take
is
you take the flow that minimizes this
and then the
the weight of a vertex the sort of
ramanian weight of the vertex
is just becomes the the amount of flow
going through it so if you think about
the flow you set up this flow problem
the flow
tries to distribute itself so as to
minimize this condition
at optimality that actually deforms the
graph into the metric you want
this is a general kind of thing that
goes on in many settings not just this
one
okay good question uh yeah
i mean you can you you can just
construct by hand the same thing
he was using you know uh you know it's
more delicate
but that's not so useful probably wants
to have some other kind of
idea what's going on it's a great
question uh
but okay so how how do you how are you
gonna analyze such a thing i'll tell you
in a second okay so for
for for larger k there's some other
constraints that you can hear that you
can put i can tell you about
them in a second if there's time but let
me tell you the basic mechanism for
how to prove that there is a lot of that
this must be large okay so you can just
think about
this very simple situation i have a
i have a planar graph
you know here are the vertices of the
planar graph
and i have to send from fba to every
pair of vertices that one unit of flow
and i want to minimize this so what can
i do okay so the first simplification
uh that we'll make without saying much
is that
we can assume that
the flow is integral okay in other words
we can assume that the flow from u to v
just concentrates for every pair on a
single path
that's just by randomized rounding it's
a you know
if uh if you have some kind of setup
like this where i send
you know i send some
some flows like this then just
independently for every pair choose one
of the paths with probability pi
okay and then if you just check uh
you'll see that you don't lose anything
there exists an integral flow which is
as good as the as the original
so now i have this graph and everybody
is sending
uh as between themselves and every other
vertex one path
and if you just open up this square for
integral flows you see that
except for the diagonal term which is
not interesting the
this is equal to the number of
intersections between the paths every
time i see an intersection i get
when you open up the square i get a you
know i get i have to count one
okay so if you uh
so uh okay so what yes what you're
really counting here is the number of
intersections between
flows from different points okay and
that's the same even if you have more
constraints
uh okay so now let's uh
let's employ this uh
a theorem so okay so actually here it's
quite simple but
if this was a planar graph so this is
drawn the plane and i draw between every
pair of points a red line and what i'm
trying to do is draw the complete graph
on n vertices in the plane and minimize
the number of crossings
which is a very well studied problem
so let me say what you can it's a very
simple down which a lot of
applications i mean you can use it to
prove some ready trotter you can use it
to prove the best sum product theorem
over the reals so it's independently due
to layton
and also to i tai shivatal
newborn and tamaretti
so for any graph g you try to draw the
graph well maybe i should use a
different letter
i already used g for our graph for any
graph h if you try to draw h in the
plane
then uh if h is fairly dense you have to
have lots and lots of crossings between
the edges
uh so
the crossing number of h is at least
the number of edges cubed
divided by the number of vertices
squared as long as
there's some kind of okay i guess
there's a constant here
uh as long as the number of edges is not
too small
so you get lots and lots of
intersections when you try to draw this
graph so actually for the k equals two
case
this completely finishes the the proof
uh it says that uh
uh in the k equals two cases that this
must be at least n to the fourth
okay sorry times the constant so a
constant times n to the fourth
because we're drawing the complete graph
let's see the complete graph has
like uh n choose two edges cubed divided
by
n squared which is uh
okay good is about n to the fourth so in
the in the case of k
equals two actually you're completely
done uh you see that they can that the
sum of the squares the conjugation must
be constant times n to the fourth
and then of course we didn't do it and
go through all the steps but if you
if you go back over here and you see
what you get uh
it's the right value okay
for the complete graph you don't need
this kind of sophistication it's a
trivial argument
uh you just well
you just use counting and the fact that
you cannot draw the complete graph on
five vertices in the plane with no
crossings and then you do double
counting and you're fine
uh yeah so for the for the complete
graph you don't need this
but once you want to go to higher k this
becomes essential
okay so let me tell you the the main
inequality
that we proved there that lets you uh
it lets you say something for okay so i
didn't tell you what the constraints are
here
but i'll tell you the inequality and
and just say i read it and uh you'll
have to accept it and be happy
you can be sad if you want as well i
can't control people's emotions despite
continued efforts anyway uh
yeah so here's here's the theorem uh
about uh
sort of uh that's actually quite you
know it turns out to be
fairly difficult to prove um okay so
but it's it's the combinatorial theorem
you need to uniformize things
uh where you don't want subsets of
measure one over k to collapse
this is uh this was this was useful just
if you don't want
very very big sets not to collapse in
the metric uh
okay so let mu uh
be a measure on subsets
of v um and then i'm going to define a
weight function using this mu
so define w of uv
this is going to be the probability
under choosing a set according to to mu
that u and v are both in the set okay
so i define this uh weight function so
it's the probability that two points
occur
at the same time in the set
um and now what do i want to do okay so
here is the theorem
we proved in the paper with shanghua
from 2009 that
given any such measure
okay so given this weight
uh you can you can instead of having
crossing number inequalities you can
talk about crossing weight inequality so
i have a weighted graph i try to draw it
whenever i see
an intersection between a pair of edges
i pay the
product of their weights okay it's a
okay so i claim that if you draw that if
you draw the complete graph or any graph
with given this
with such a weight function then the
total crossing weight
is at least uh
is at least this okay so this is the
main technical theorem
uh the total crossing weight you
encourage at least one over n times the
expected size of the set squared to the
five halves
uh and this i mean this uses and and i
guess i should say that
this uses this theorem as a black box so
but you have to apply it to many many
different graphs
if i had stated this slightly more
generally than it would be
but at the moment it's not uh but
if you i guess sort of one thing to say
to see how it relates back
is that uh if your measure is
concentrated on sets of size at least n
over k
so if mu is supported
on such sets then the thing with the the
example which shows this is tight
is just to choose your distribution you
partition
your n vertices into k sets of size
n over k
and the distribution which shows this is
tight is just to choose one of these
case sets uniformly at random
okay so the the the extremal
distribution for this inequality
is really the dual telling you exactly
where to build your bump functions
uh so that you get an upper bound on the
eigenvalue
okay uh yeah so um
okay and there is a
yeah this this is sort of as i mean this
has the feelings of sort of many kind of
theorems we've seen here it has a
density increment argument and
as i said a number of applications of
kosher sorts
let me not belabor this i just want to
say two things about this
uh one is about sort of these crossing
number inequalities in general
and then the other is an open question
yeah so the first thing is
oh this constant yeah this is central
this is crucial so and it's
this is the right bound yeah so it's
tight for all ranges of the size of the
set
and i should say that you know in order
to in order to prove the theorem you
only need to prove you don't need to
prove such a theorem for
measures which are concentrated on sets
aside and over k but in order for the
induction to work
sort of you need this more general kind
of statement okay
so i guess two things are in order here
um one interesting thing is that as uh
as was pointed out this
i mean the validity of this crossing
number inequality
doesn't have much to do with uh planar
graphs it has only to do with the
existence of sort of
small forbidden substructures so for
instance uh
although there is no although there is
not any
easily accessible notion of sort of like
what
uh uh sort of a of a uniformization for
three-dimensional graphs
in the conformal sense these techniques
still work for instance if you're
uh you know okay so suppose you're in r3
and your graph was the nerve of some
sphere packing in r3
with the constraint that that adjacent
these are in r3 they look like they're
in r2
okay
happy little spheres uh
yeah as long as the adjacent spheres
have uh as long as they're radii within
a constant factor
then these techniques also work here and
the reason is because you can also
identify forbidden substructures here
and so the crossing techniques go
through it's an interesting way in which
uh sort of you can generalize crossing
number inequalities to
things that are sort of not
two-dimensional you can go
i don't know if there are any other
applications of this but
you can prove spectral bounds on on
higher dimensional graphs
that's one thing and then i guess uh
i want to conclude with a question about
uniformization
uh which is a very different sort so
this was very low dimensional
uh i like it because it connects sort of
to
a sort of classical rimani and geometry
but suppose you wanted to
do something like you wanted to attack
the unique games conjecture
or some other problems let me give a
uniformization problem
uh of a high dimensional nature uh which
i think is very
important uh and the point is that uh if
you try to solve it you end up in a
similar kind of setting you have
extremal metrics you have you have to
need to analyze some flows
and i just don't know how to do it well
enough so here's the problem
some of you have seen this problem
before unfortunately some of you have
seen it many times before
okay but uh but
it's still on the it's still open so
shame on you
uh okay uh suppose that the graph is a
vertex expander so what it means is just
that uh
if i if i look at the vertex
neighborhood of a subset of nodes
then it grows by some constant factor
the constant factor is not so important
i guess i should put some constraint on
the size of the set so
every set of size at most uh half girls
by
ten percent okay uh
no no this is in the vertex sense i'm
looking at the vertex neighborhood
i didn't say anything about the degrees
of this graph unlike the
most of the expanders we've seen the
degrees could be huge okay
uh so here's my question uh
so so i mean this graph could look very
bad all right because i didn't say
anything about the degrees
you can do all kinds of things like you
can take the product of a graph
with some uh with some kind of tiny
complete graph
which will you know make it will sort of
make it look locally very dense whereas
globally it could be sparse
uh this graph could sort of like the
actual true nature of the geometry this
graph could
be could be very uh hidden okay
so i want to say i want to say something
about uniforming eyes again so it's it's
more
apparent okay so here's the here's the
conjecture
the conjecture is that there exists a
random walk
supported on g okay what does it mean
uh there's a random walk that goes along
the edges of g
how what what do you have to choose you
get to choose the probability when you
when you're sitting at a vertex you get
to choose the probability that you go
over which edges you go over
okay the conjectures there exist a
random walk supported on g
that mixes to the uniform distribution
in uh order log
n steps
this is the conjecture okay so if g was
a constant degree expander then you can
just throw your hands up when you finish
because you know you're mixing or log n
steps but if g is some
possibly you know different graph where
sort of the uh the structure is obscured
by the you know
i can i'll even let you put you know you
can put a bunch of self loops in g this
will slow the random walk down to an
arbitrary extent
but when you can choose what to do you
can just put you know you can take these
self loops with weight zero so you don't
have to take them
uh so i can prove it
for uh for log n
squared uh mixing time and if you could
prove for log n it would have lots of uh
applications for instance it would give
a sub exponential time
1.9 approximation vertex cover okay
a sub x minute like you could get vertex
cover is a problem on graphs you know
uh getting better in the two
approximation is probably very hard
with so we think but if you can solve
this you will get a 1.9 approximation
not in polynomial time but in times
two to the you know and in fact two to
the n to the point zero zero one
and in fact you know you can prove log n
squared
and this has no indication for this uh
it has an implication that you can solve
the problem in exponential time but
that's
less less interesting
you just learned what a troll is at
dinner a few nights ago right so now are
you asking if i'm trolling
yes i mean and i mean i was on
sabbatical here last year and you know
six months of my time was wasted trying
to prove it so i believe it this much
okay uh okay so let me end there
thanks
any questions for james
yeah so can you explain what's the
relation to
vertex color and uh
if you want to solve it you're assuming
your graph is a vertical expander
yeah no okay so how is it related
uh you write down some semi-definite
program so if you uh
uh if you cannot solve the semi-definite
program by some
straightforward method it means that uh
it means that the vertices of sort of
embedded in some high-dimensional space
you can build a graph on them which is a
vertex expander now
if the vertex expander had some nice
mixing properties it would give you some
kind of
local global relationship between the
graphs so the fact that
basically local mixing means that local
correlation of functions along say edges
corresponds to global correlation in the
graph
so basically uh if you could so
you get this you will if you cannot
solve the problem you will get this
vertex expander embedded there
if you could put some weights on it so
the random walk mixed fast
it would say that actually that's the
semi-definite program cannot be doing
very good because they would say that
the fact that it's doing well along
edges means it's also
sort of uh means the fact that the stp
solution is correlated on edges means
it's also correlated for random pairs
which will contradict some of the
constraints this is probably
not useful or not really but
yeah so you say existence of these
random vlogs
yes this is enough yes are you
enumerating
because you're just saying you're not
saying that you need to find it
uh well there's always this okay so
first of all
uh there is a way
possibly to find it efficiently assuming
it exists but but even besides this
at least you know in all these things
getting the value of the vertex cover is
already
an interesting problem so even so if you
can do this it would it would bound the
value of the semi-definite program
so there would be no integration again
whether you can construct it is a
different matter although
okay the answer to this is a little more
subtle but
the i mean then you should say you
should not say that there is an
algorithm you should say that
what do you mean there is an algorithm
for outputting the value
there is just an algorithm to find no
that's a that's an ugly conjecture this
one is very nice
okay so it's a good question here you
can even here uh
it's l2 mixing time suffices but here i
the conjecture
is for l infinity mixing
you know make it as strong as possible
but l2 mixing would suffice for the
application
so if if you replace
the part of the conjecture of the random
walk on the graph
by a random walk on uh
not not a random walk to adjacent uh
notes but a random walk two notes that
are a little bit
further yes then you've all has a as a
paper yes uh yeah
that's why you're asking so that would
uh there's a paper of nara rabbani in
sinclair which says that
if you allow your random walk to be
supported not on the edges of the graph
but on edge on pairs of distance at most
root log n in the graph
then you can do it what if it's shorter
i mean this version of the
yeah so uh if you would like to go to
log into the one-fourth or something
yeah then i don't know what happens yeah
so we know that there is a strong
connection between projection
and the eigenvalues and so basically you
are building your proof on that
yes but so somehow usually they can the
it goes in the other way like you you
have some you know some argument you get
and then
reduce that the congestion is is small
let's say because
the eigenvalue gap is it's large right
so
but so but here you are going in the
other way but you need some very precise
things so is there like a precise way of
going
from the eigenvalues uh to the
congestions
like if you know the first the
eigenvalues that you can say something
better
than just if you know the verb if you
know the
just the eigenvalue yeah makes it
usually these these congestion arguments
are used to put lower bounds on the
eigenvalues
right that's usually the i mean you put
some nice graph with magnetic gap inside
your graph
and now you're saying can you can you
see the version of this which would
which would
bound more of the spectrum i mean yes so
you know
so you know the spectrum pretty
precisely that not only the first
i mean but the first k
and can you say something more about the
congestion
so here now you know a lot about the
congestion and so you deduce
information about the first k
eigenvalues so can you vote
in the other way i i i believe the
answer is yes
up to a logarithmic factor in the
eigenvalue bound
logarithmic vectors sometimes are not so
important for this problem logarithmic
factors would crush you
but uh i think the answer is yes if
you're willing to lose a logarithmic
factor yeah
yeah so when you look at the flow
problem which is the dual of funding and
extremal magic yeah
for a larger k the problem finding an
external metric
it's uh hard at all yes
so you would expect the dual to be less
constraint for larger k
yes which means it has more constraints
uh no they're just they're just longer
to write down okay
yeah no no you have weaker constraints
which means that the structure theorem
has to be stronger in order to prove
that
any such system has a large congestion
yeah
there they are weaker than this
constraint
okay thank you